I'm sorry esta página amazing kiss and I
was and still am a your modem PRS to
this wall starting from the very first
knife from the 21st of November it was
very first night when old people came
out in the street the protest this is an
organic or which not to move towards
European Union now with one of the 100
people who went there at night and since
then I've been going to my done every
day and think that kept me there and
still keeps me there is the I truly
believe that Ukrainian nation is very
very very strong and humid on PR through
this idea very much many many years
people treated ukraine ukrainian people
for centuries of slaves because we never
attacked in the history we always turned
it all end but this happened once more
renault aggressive we're just defending
what we have and our motherland's and
year it was proved once one more time
that we're not too late will not be
Leo's down I would say the distillation
happened after rush appeared in between
Ukrainian so this division is truly
horrible is where all Ukrainians
royalties for one nation and people
divided themselves think you know the
Western people and the central and the
eastern which is very bad so there was
never such division before
was the revival of Ukrainian nation so
we do not have any such big explosions
of patriotism and realization of
ourselves is a one big United fee for
people through your core Ukrainians the
land and the district for preserving
that the borders of preserving the
spirits of Ukraine and not wanting like
for example Russian language to be
second official leaders who want to
preserve this identity and the culture
had for many many many centuries
subscribe on YouTube follow us on
Twitter and like us on Facebook